done
はぁんっ
はぁんっん
[音楽]
ん
me
今日は消極性デザインという考え方についてお話しにしました
私は大学の先生をしていますのでこういうプレゼンの場は普通の人よりは慣れていると
いう方だと思います
でも今からねぇ
見て分かりの通り緊張しています
そんな緊張 c の私がプレゼンよりももっと緊張してしまうのが懇親会というやつ
です
大きな学会なんかになりますと大きな部屋に100人以上の人が集まって思い思いに話
をして仲良くなって
時にはその後一緒に研究をするようになったりする
そういうイベントです
私も最初は
あのすごい発表していた人とお話してみたいと声を買ってみようと思ったりしてるん
です
でもその人は既に他の人と話が弾んでいたりして
私なんかと話しても面白くないかもしれないな
などと考えすぎてしまっている自民アキがすれば私たち一人方
せめて恥ずかしいから指令を探して話しかけよう
そんなふうにしているうちに終わってしまう
いうことがあります
学生でも社会人でもちょっと同じようなイベントがあって
私と同じように消極的になっているしまってる人っていうと思うんです
もしかしたらそんなところに立ってい
いるだけでも積極的な方じゃないかと1回を超え化してみようと思うんでしょうとか
私ならそもそもとても消極的だから懇親会なんか参加しない人というふうに言いたく
なった人もいるかもしれません
でも一つ言わせてください
そういう私のほうが消極的私こそが本物の消極的みたいに張り合うのはやめにし
ましょう
だって今時誰になって消極的になってしまうときがある
そういう時代だからです
分かりやすいのは twitter だと思います
私にツイッタースッキリよくするんですけれどもいろんな人からフォローされます
でも別にフォローし返さなくてもいいし
follow 主体だけしてコミュニケーションも主体だけする
そういうとても
受け身でいられる頑張らなくてもいいところがウケているそういうアプリだと思うん
です
そういうアプリが受けている時代に懇親会だからといって頑張るというのは何か違うん
じゃないかと私は思います
懇親会だって頑張らなくてもコミュニケーションできればいいなと私は常々思う
その話をしているといやもっと積極的になりなよとお叱りになりたい人も中にはいるか
もしれません
でもそういう人もお供とは消極的で気合でうまくできるようになってきたからこそ自分
もできたんだからお前も気合いでなんとかしろとそういうふうな人が多いんじゃないか
と思うんです
でも私はその気合いをもっと別のことに向けたらいいよという風に考えてしまいます
コミュニケーションが楽になればそのエネルギーをもっと他の事に向けられるんじゃ
ないかというふうに思うんです
話を懇親会に戻しましょう
懇親会も今 c 返しますというだけでうまく交流できる人ばかりじゃないなという
ふうなことを考えてちょっと工夫してみようという風に考えるとれる人もなかにいます
そうすると私はですねあそういう懇親会なら私でもうまく交流できるかもしれないと
いうふうに伝えを胸に参加してみるわけです
でもいざフタを開けてみると実写エイムが始まったりするんですね
ジェスチャーゲーム今からお題を出しますのでジェスチャーだけでそれを表現して
ください
豪華景品を用意してますので頑張ってくださいそんなゲームです
うわぁやりたくないん
思うんですねー
でも言う勇気がありません
周りにもずっとそんな人がいるはずです
せめて難しいお題が感銘してくれ野球ぐらいに教えてくれという心の声が私には聞こえ
てきます
しかしその願いはボロく持ち方彼
ハヤリのお笑いデーに埋めてをいきなり人前でやらされることになったりするわけです
イベントの主催者をするような人っていうのはだいたい積極的な人で
そういう盛り上がれば何とかなるという風な考え方をする人が多いように思います
私はこれはそういう人に任せてはいけないよ
消極的な私の人ような人が何とかするしかないなというふうに思うようになったんです
ある学会で私はいう職責締めシステムというものを作ることになりました
どういうシステムかというとパソコンとかスマートフォンで事前に
誰々さんの近くの席になりたいというふうにほっそりとこう
登録していくことができると
そうしておくとシステムが自動的になるべく多くの人の願いを叶えてくれるように席を
決めてくれるとそういうシステムです
あそんなシステムがあれば私も憧れのあの人とお話できるかもしれない
そんな懇親会では参加してみたいというふうに思ってくれた人もいるかもしれません
でも私は何しろ消極的なのでまだそれでは安心できませんでした
憧れの音1と3でたくシステムが隣の席にしてくれた時のことを想像してみましょう
なんでこの人となりなったんだと私はこの人と話したいが登録してないと
なるほど
この人は私と話したいか登録しちゃったというふうに希望がばれてしまう
それだったらお隣ですかといって座っていくのと同じじゃないかと
それができないからクロスとかなというふうに私は思いました
せっかく大がかりなシステムをわざわざ作るんだったら
消極的な人が安心して交流できるようなシステムを作りたいと
何よりも私が安心して参加したいというふうに思ったんです
そこで私がどうしたかというと希望の登録の仕方を変えました
私が誰々さんと近くになりたいというふうに登録するのではなくてええええなぁさんと
b さんが近くの席になったらいいなというふうに登録できるそんなシステムにしまし
た
そうすると二人の1オナコードのように引き合わせてあげる
イメージですねそういうシステムです
もちろんどちらかの名前をこっそりと自分にしておけば自分の希望も登録することが
できるとそういうシステムです
もう一度あこがれの人と隣の席になった時のことをイメージしてみましょう
相手はやっぱりなんでこの人となりになったんだろうこの人が私と話したかったのかな
というふうに思います
でも待てよと他の人が登録者のかもしれないとわからないなというふうに希望がバレ
にくくなるというわけです
難しいことではないんです
非常にちょっとした工夫です
でもよっぽど消極的な人でなければそこまで風しようとは考えません
詔勅的だからこそ消極的な人が安心して参加できるそういう工夫を考えることができる
のです
私はそういう工夫だことを詔勅性デザインと呼んでいます
英語ではシャイハックと呼んでいます
消極性で悩んでる人っていうのはですねなかなか他の人に渡しこういうことで悩んで
いるということが言えないということもあると思います
そもそも詔勅せいで悩んでいるということに関しては普通の人は努力や根性で解決
しようという風に思い込んでいますのでなかなかそういう発想すら出てきにくいという
ことがあるんじゃないかなと
思います
そういう空気が少しずつでも変わって詔勅性の問題も工夫でなんとかしてみようという
ふうに思ってくれる人が増えたら私はうれしいです
といってもシステムを作るのは難しいんでしょ
プログラミングとかしなきゃいけないでしょうそれだったらまだ積極的になろうが簡単
そう
そんな風にもしかしたら思われた人もいるかもしれません
確かに私は消極的で
緊張しなんですけどプログラミングは得意だったのでそういうシステムを作ることが
できました
でも私もいつもし最初なわけではないのでプログラミングができたからといっていつも
私のシステムを使ってもらえるわけではありません
そんな13カ所で三角として参加する時でも私は何かしらのシャイ発行を準備していき
ます
私が今一番お気に入りの車泊は好きなものも t シャツ落ちていくというものです
今も来ているんですけれども
ついたら好きなんですねこういう格好をして懇親会に参加すると向こうの方から
twitter 好きなんですがツイッターやるんですがこういうを買ってもらうこと
ができます
自分から声をかけなくてもいいというだけでもかなり救われます
しかも twitter の話をすればいいので自分の好きなものの話をすればいいの
で
自分の土俵の上で戦うことができるとそういうシャイハーフです
もっとやれてがないと思います温度の懇親会どうしても参加しなきゃいけないらしいん
だけどもう話をする気力もない
その時もありますその時は私はちょっといいごついカメラを首から提げていきます
そうすると会場に1人でいたとしても私は
懇親会の撮影係に見えるね
一人でいても恥ずかしくないとそういうシャイ把握です
もしかしたら写真撮ってくださいぐらいは声をかけられることがあるかもしれませんが
まあ写真を撮ればいいんです
でもし合っラッキーこの人とお話してみたいという人が近づいてきた時には実は私は
撮影係じゃなくて参加さんなんですとってお話すればいいとそういうツイッターのよう
な気軽さがある
シャイ泊だと思っています
大沼湖それぐらいなら私でもできるかもという気がしてきませんか
消極的な人が自分の悩みを自分で解決すれば
同じような悩みで苦しんでいる消極的な人あるいは
気合でなんとかうまくできてる人そんな人たちが少しずつ楽になります
消極的な人はそういう解決した方がいい問題にいち早く
ことができる優れた才能の持ち主だと私は思っています
皆さんの心の中にある詔勅星の数だけ
詔勅性デザインをたねもあります
私たちがあって懇親会は大好きなんだけど
プレゼンはすごく上がってしまってダメダメなんですという人もいるかもしれません
コミュニケーションはだいたい大丈夫なんだけど何か新しいことを始めようと思っても
すぐ辞めてしまうと三日坊主になってしまうんですという風に悩んでいる人もいるかも
しれません
大体私はいつも積極的なんだけど異性と話すときだけピンポイントに消極的になって
しまうという人もいるかも知れます
皆さんそんな自分をどうやったら変えられるだろうと長年悩んできた
でももしかしたら変えられなかっ
私は
違う方法を試してみるべきだというふうに思います
ぜひみなさん自分なりの消極性デザインを考えてみてください
これは先生からの宿題です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]